and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we got a special guest today
did we do professional baseball player
James clear no no no it's not he he he
had a brief stent with baseball he talks
about a like in the very beginning of
his amazing book yeah no that he's not a
professional baseball player but he
looks like one for sure all right well
this is episode 165 and it's coming out
on New Year's Day and so what better
time to talk about habits of course yeah
you can listen to this any time of the
year because it's always a good time to
talk about reconsidering your habits but
this is the time of year James that
people really I guess reflect back on
all the bad decisions they've made over
the course of the last 12 months or 37
years in my case and and we look back
and say I need to I need to change this
right I've developed a routine that is
not beneficial that is not theirs not
advantageous for living the life that I
want to live and so we have today James
Clare he's he is the author of this
amazing book atomic habit so James we
don't really interview people but I did
have a question for you before we dive
into some of these questions how did you
become the habits guy what how do all of
this happen oh man well good to talk to
you both thanks for having me guys
thank you being here man we really
appreciate it so I mean everybody has
habits right like you're building them
all the time whether you want to or not
so I felt like it made sense to think
more carefully about how that happens
and like can we design them rather than
have them happen to us and my first
exposure to it was what Ryan mentioned
was through baseball and sports you know
like any athlete can tell you there are
all kinds of habits you're building when
you're at practice or you know in the
gym or things like that and so I got
exposed to it there and then I've spent
the last 6 years just kind of like
writing about the ideas and sharing them
on my site and gradually narrowing in on
what I think it takes to build good
habits and break bad ones so so you've
been vlogging over at james clear calm
correct and and and sort of I guess
refining your ideas about what it takes
to to build good habits replace bad
habits and I think really that's
a lot of our questions that we have
today from our audience or so I think we
should just go head and dive in and
start answering some of the questions
yeah um well let's just talk about his
book real quick and how awesome his book
is okay um I just you know before we
dive into the questions I do just want
to say that James sent me an email is
like hey man I wrote a new book would
love to send you a copy like like any
good friend yes send me a copy of your
book I don't like the first chapter and
I was like oh my god like this is one of
the best books I've ever read on habits
like we've got to get him on the podcast
but I went out and I bought at least two
copies and I sent one of my mom I sent
one of my brother because it is such a
just a simple approach man and I think
with any type of nonfiction especially
like us I don't want to call you your
Jon or self help but I can't think of
anything else right now but it is a sort
of self help Josh and I - or in you know
sort of that realm as well but sure I
fact I've I've sort of reclaimed the the
positive side of that because for me is
like of course I want to help myself
shirt and if I can help others by
expressing how I help myself
the problem with the the sort of moniker
of self-help is is there's a lot of
vapid woowoo nonsense out there and and
the difference about what what you're
talking about in fact you even you have
it right here on the cover is like it's
it's a proven way of of reflecting back
on bad habits and in making the positive
changes that that you want to make yeah
I want like all of my ideas should be
scientifically based so I feel like
that's the difference between
traditional self-help and the type of
stuff I write but a Chinese point and to
your point about you want to be able to
help yourself I think the idea should
not just be scientific but also
actionable yeah right and that that's
the key is like I want to have something
I can actually apply in daily life that
is what I really liked about your book
dude is that it it's simple advice and
it's simple steps it's not like this
grand like I didn't finish this book
feeling like oh my god I got so much
work ahead of me mmm like I finished
this book I was like oh my god like it's
not as hard as I really like when I look
at it through your lens incorporating
good habits in my life were changing bad
ones really isn't as difficult if
anything I was like
I gotta go through this book again
because there are so many like I just
I'm just gonna like open up to a couple
of things I underlined here man but like
you've got just tweetable one tweetable
line after tweetable line in here over
the long run however the real reason you
fail to stick with habits is that your
self-image gets in the way this is why
you can't get too attached to one
version of your identity it's so true
dude it's like I mean going back to your
example with being a baseball player if
you you know you you went through your
high school college you're playing
baseball if you expect it to be a
professional baseball player and all of
a sudden you realize like oh this isn't
gonna happen for me
and you were so wrapped up into that
identity you may have never written this
book and it's just like little stuff
like that that I'm reading through this
book and I'm like oh my god like I
remember tweet as soon as I got a copy
the book dude like I started tweeting
there's some lines from it cuz it was it
was really incredible but the other
thing too I like about this book is at
the end of each chapter you got little
highlights summaries yeah dude it's it's
such a good idea because there will be
like there was something I was
referencing and I forgot what chapter
was in and I was like oh I just goes for
the summaries and sure enough like found
what I was looking for word because of
the summary and that's alright that was
a nice little touch - man yeah that's
cool thank you so much I'm glad you
enjoyed it
and yeah I think my hope is that the
ideas will be scientifically grounded
but also easy to understand and sounds
like it landed that way with you and I
look at people like you know if Richard
Fineman can write about physics or
Stephen Hawking can write about the
origin of the universe and their books
can be fairly easy to read it's like
nobody else has an excuse right like
that the job of a writer is to make it
digestible and easy to use and so I like
looking at examples like that to try to
inspire me to write in a better way oh
yeah I teach a writing class and one of
the things that I try to explain to
students is there is a difference
between communicative writing and
expressive writing like a calculus
textbook is just communicative and it
can be all grounded in all the science
but it's also boring a [ __ ] and like you
don't want to take you don't want to
take the the calculus textbook to the
beach or even to the airport and read it
on on the plane expressive writing on
the other hand like extreme expression
is
you know a manic person running down the
middle of the street just yelling it
require traffic yeah requires no
audience whatsoever right and and I
think the beauty of of blending the
communication actually communicating
something but doing it in a way that is
expressive makes people want to read it
and so you talked about the the identity
thing Ryan you brought that up I found
for me that was one of the hardest
things to let go of people often asked
like what was the hardest thing for you
to get rid of and they expect me to say
well it was a big screen TV or my second
Lexus or something and and the honest
answer is like the hardest thing to let
go of was my identity and it's the first
thing we ask someone right what do you
do and then we have to recite like what
is our job title that's on the business
card what fits on the business card that
is Who I am as a person and we get so
tethered to that identity that it's
suffocating and it becomes difficult to
make a change that that doesn't align
with that identity well you see this in
all kinds of areas right you get like
the band that gets locked in to their
first album and then like it's hard for
them to create or make something new or
you have like the manager who's always
done it like his way and that's the way
that you know the department has to run
and but more lucky and you get to end to
that identity or like the the surgeon
who her particular strategy for
surgeries like the way to go even though
the up-and-coming residents want to use
some kind of new technology or something
and like that conflict is basically
identity conflict at some level right
it's like I identify as this kind of
person who does this type of thing and
change runs counter to that and with
respect to minimalism a lot of the items
that we have like you said oh people
think oh maybe it's a big-screen TV or a
car or something but really it's what
those things represent yeah right it's
like I you don't get the Lexus just
because you need a car you get it
because it's a status signal right
because you think it represents
something it it represents the identity
that you want to show to the people
around you and so in a lot of ways the
process of behavior change is really
identity change right like it's you're
really asking someone to not get rid of
something or change a behavior you're
asking them to like see themselves in a
new light and once you can do that then
the process of like getting rid of the
car giving away the TV that's easy
that's just the logistical thing it's
almost like anti advertising in a way
because you talked about the the Lexus
thing the in fact what they're trying to
do is have you identify with that object
right that expensive you know sixty
eighty thousand dollar object in fact I
remember a few years ago the marketing
campaign they may even still use this as
their slogan it was like they say money
can't buy happiness
those people are spending their money
wrong and and and the the well the
implicit message there is this Lexus
will make you happy right and and
without even defining what happiness
really means I mean what what a
squirrely word that is and we've had so
many conversations about the difference
between happiness and joy and
satisfaction and peace and contentment
and all these things are used
synonymously and I even I use them
synonymously but but they they tend to
embody different states and and I think
one thing that we've realized the reason
that we stumble into these bad habits
that we have established these bad
habits they are they are a way to give
us that ephemeral pleasure the you know
the smokiness cigarette is a is a in a
very easy example because that's the
stereotypical sort of bad habit but it
changes our state immediately and so we
develop these bad habits through routine
and we develop good habits
it seems to me through deliberate or
intentional action and in your book that
you obviously talk about the ways to
move away from bad habits to good habits
and a lot of our questions today are
about that
let me read one more thing I want to ask
James a question so just again flipping
through like this tons of stuff I got
underlined here you've got this part and
I think it's a second chapter every
action you take is a vote for the type
of person you wish to become no single
instance will transform your beliefs but
as the votes build up so does the
evidence of your new identity and then a
little bit more down the page you wrote
every time you choose to perform a bad
habit it's a vote for that identity so
the reason why this stands out to me a
is because I mean it's it's spot-on and
I love to think about well when people
talk about
minimalism and the things they bring
into the lives or the resources that
they use those are all votes for for who
we want to be and who we are but also it
speaks to why your book is called atomic
habits so maybe explain that a little
bit before we dive into these questions
so what what why atomic habits yeah sure
so I chose the phrase atomic habits for
three reasons
so the first meaning of the word atomic
is what you might expect right like tiny
or small like an atom and that's a core
piece of my philosophy like habits
should be small and easy to do
the second meaning of the word atomic
and the one that's often overlooked is
the fundamental unit in a larger system
so like atoms building two molecules
molecules building two compounds and so
on and in a way our habits are sort of
like the atoms of our lives you know
like they're these little routines that
you do each day and when you put them
all together you end up with this larger
system of your daily routine and then
the third and final meaning of the word
atomic is the source of immense energy
or power and I think that if you combine
all three of those meanings you
understand the narrative arc of the book
which is if you make changes that are
small and easy to do and you layer them
on top of each other like units and a
larger system then you end up with some
really powerful or remarkable results in
the long run yeah do you differentiate
habits from routine and if so how
yeah so technically speaking yes they're
different so the technical definition of
a habit is a behavior that's been
repeated enough to be more or less
automatic right you can do it pretty
much without thinking so tying your
shoes brushing your teeth unplugging the
toaster after each use like stuff like
that
but we often use the word habit in a
broader sense right like you might say I
want to get in the habit of writing or I
want to build the habit of going to the
gym and I know what you mean when you
say that technically that would be more
of a routine because the routine is kind
of a repeated practice but it doesn't
necessarily have to be automatic or non
conscious but I think the key
distinction here and this is where
habits can be really useful is that
habits often initiate routines so for
example you might have a habit of
answering email for an hour each day and
while you're answering emails you're not
totally on autopilot you're thinking
carefully about how to respond to the
message and so on but it's often the
habit the automatic non conscious action
of pulling your phone out of your pocket
that initiates the routine
of responding to email and so I think a
key point here is that and this is why I
like to recommend people start if
they're looking to like build a new
habit one good place to start is with
what I call the two-minute rule so the
basic idea is you take whatever habit
you're trying to build and you scale it
down to just the first two minutes
because you can't you often cannot
automate an entire routine right like
writing writing is about effortful as it
gets right you're not just gonna go on
autopilot for an hour but you can
automate the first action you can
automate the habit kind of like habits
are sorta like an entrance ramp to the
highway right so using this two-minute
rule you take whatever routine you're
trying to build whatever big goal you're
looking at say it's like I want to read
50 books a year and you scale it down to
just the first two minutes so it's like
read one page or do yoga four days a
week and that becomes like take out my
yoga mat and stuff like that is quick
enough and repetitive enough that you
could like automate the start of it and
then that kind of sends you in the right
direction
also you mentioned writing in fact our
first question is about writing and
we'll get into that a second but I know
one of the things that that for me I you
top a habit being the exit ramp onto the
the highway here of routine but for me I
had a bunch of roadblocks on the exit
ramp right I had all these rules set up
for me that I will start riding once
I've made my coffee and the laundry is
folded and I've swept the floor and I've
removed the dishes from the dishwasher
and like they're all of these these
rules I set up and so inevitably I'd
have 15 rules set up fifteen roadblocks
and I'd remove 14 of them but there was
always one I always had one additional
excuse and part of that is because
you're afraid to actually just do the
work because it seems well when you
think of the full routine it seems so
overwhelming it's like let me put one
other roadblock up that prevents me from
doing so I have an excuse in a way and
so for me I real also realize in order
to make the habit and easier or simpler
I had to remove those roadblocks have
fewer rules for me the rule now is I
have to wake up like that's my only rule
in order to start writing is I have to
wake up in the morning now if I could
remove that rule and start writing in my
sleep that'd be even better
but that is my one rule the dishes might
not be done the the coffee's not made or
whatever but as long as I wake up then
that's my trigger to get into that habit
of writing and eventually it becomes a
it does become a routine and speaking of
that our first question is from Keanu in
Washington I'm certainly not a writer
but sometimes I feel like I could
benefit by writing in a journal in
French perhaps but I don't I'm not good
at that and do you have any tips about
how to create those habit or a good
approach all right so a few things here
that stood out to me in Kiana's question
she wants to develop the habit for
writing so that that is a step in the
right direction although she has thrown
up her own roadblocks here James she
said I'm not a writer as as though like
there are certain babies that are born
with a quill in their hand and all of a
sudden they've come out of the womb
ready to to write the the perfect Don
DeLillo novel or something she said I'm
not good at that
well I mean I don't think anyone's good
at writing about my daughters five right
and she's a terrible riot you see the
novel she tried to write hardly spell my
name and and so the thing is you're not
good at it until you get better at it
and and the thing that I realized like
it took me most of my 20s and by the way
I held the writing of my twenties fairly
precious as well like for me like
everything that came off of my pen was
like man this is gorgeous even though it
was terrible in retrospect I you look
back I wrote a novel in my 20s and it
was actually the best of the the stuff
that that didn't hit the cutting room
floor and and there are pieces in there
that are truly gorgeous but it took all
the sediment to find the gold so to
speak and the thing that I would tell
Keanu is thing I tell tell writing
students is in fact I tricked them into
taking my writing class it's not really
a writing class it's a habits class
that's focused around writing it's nice
it's getting people to to actually write
every day it's
one of the weird things there are a few
things like this where people aspire to
be a writer but they don't actually do
the writing you don't know anyone who
aspires to be like a bricklayer but what
has never like laid a brick before and
they're like well I'm I'm just one day
I'll be a bricklayer yeah but with
writing we somehow expect through
osmosis or something osmosis in in
motivation like so like I know for me
one of the hardest barriers to get past
is like waiting on that motivation to
write and real and you know realizing
years and years ago like oh if I'm if
I'm gonna wait on the motivation to
write or if I'm gonna wait on the
motivation to go out start laying bricks
to become a bricklayer
I'll be waiting my whole life I'll just
there just be aspiration everywhere
nothing at all people are like that they
wake up each day and wonder like oh
maybe today will be the day I feel like
writing or maybe today will be the day I
feel like going to the gym and it
doesn't work the podcast Sean who was it
was a Faulkner or was it Fitzgerald who
said I I make sure that he I write only
when I'm inspired and I make sure I'm
inspired every morning at 8:30 I was
Falkner okay yeah yeah and and the the
key is like you it's it's the
inspiration doesn't have to be this
grandiose thing you don't have to be hit
with an inspiration stick every morning
in order to to feel inspired so what
what advice do you have for Keanu James
is she if she wants to start journaling
she thinks journaling would be
beneficial and I actually in my writing
class I I distinguish between journaling
which i think is pretty much just
expressive writing and then writing for
a public audience although I think
journaling can also be a good place to
start but if she wants to build this
habit where does she start sure so I
think there are two core issues you
brought up one already this idea of like
oh I'm not good at that or I'm not a
writer and this goes back to what Ryan
brought up earlier about the identity
piece right and you see this with all
kinds of habits people will say things
like you know I have a sweet tooth or
I'm terrible at remembering directions
or I'm not good at math and as soon as
you internalize those kind of identities
then doing that action becomes much less
desirable right if you think like oh I'm
terrible or writing well then you sit
down to write and you kind of have this
internal resistance so the natural next
question is are
that makes sense but then what do I
actually do like how do I get over that
right and this is where we come back to
the evidence piece and this is where I
think my philosophy and approach differs
a little bit from what you typically
hear which are things like fake it till
you make it or something like that and
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
fake it till you make it
there's nothing wrong with like
believing yourself for being positive
but it's a short-term strategy not a
long-term one because fake it till you
make it asks you to believe something
about yourself that you don't have
evidence for and there we have a word
for beliefs that don't have evidence we
call delusion right like at some point
the brain doesn't like that and you have
this conflict so the way to develop and
believe in a new identity the way to see
yourself as a writer is to cast small
votes excuse me is to cast small votes
for that identity so in the case of
journaling which I think it could be a
great way to start I actually we have a
journal a habit journal coming out in
January and it's specifically designed
for this purpose which is that a lot of
people say I would like to start
journaling and then they think it needs
to be this huge lofty gold I think that
it needs to be this thing where they
write like three pages a day or
something but instead this journal is
designed around write one sentence and
so you just write one sentence about
each day and that is a simple way for
her to start and I have a friend who
teaches English and is a poet and his
daily writing habit is to write one
sentence and there are many days where
he will write a full page but on the bad
days he still gets one sentence in which
is better than nothing at all and it's
kind of a key for establishing these
identities right like let's say that you
want to become a fit person but you
don't see yourself in that way right now
well you could just like try to do
something crazy and join a CrossFit gym
or start doing p90x or insanity or
something like that and this is what a
lot of people do right especially around
January you get amped up yes we get into
this all-or-nothing mentality and you do
that for like three weeks and then you
fall of course and you slide back to
what you normally did and then like
three months later you do it all over
again you feel like oh I need to get in
shape or whatever but I had a reader who
ended up losing over a hundred pounds
and one of the first things they did was
he went to the gym but he wasn't allowed
to stay for longer than five minutes so
he would get in the car
drive to the gym get out do like half an
exercise get back in the car drive home
and it sounds silly when you first hear
about it right sounds ridiculous it's
like why would that do anything but what
you realize is he was mastering the art
of showing up he was becoming the type
of person that went to the gym four days
a week because if you're not the type of
person that drives to the gym you have
no hope of being the kind of person that
like actually works out there for a
while and so he basically fostered that
identity of being that kind of person
who showed up and this is a key insight
about building better habits whether
it's Kiana and her writing habit or
fitness habits or whatever a habit must
be established before it can be improved
and so the very first thing to do is to
master the art of showing up it's not to
worry about the performance it's not to
worry about what the writing looks like
I had to do this with myself right like
I when I started building James Clerk
aam I wrote a new article every Monday
and Thursday and my the way that I made
it happen was it didn't matter how long
or how short the work was it doesn't
didn't matter how good or how bad it was
it didn't matter how I felt about it if
all I could do was write one good
paragraph that's what I was doing but
something had to get out on Monday and
Thursday and after I did that for three
years I turned around now I view myself
as a writer but it didn't start that way
right and you were less concerned about
whatever that in manifestation of what a
writer means being a writer in in
Kiana's mine is like well why don't know
what she means by I'm not a writer I you
haven't published seven books or
something because if so then I'm not a
writer right because I've only published
four books Soleil I'm still trying and
and for me I'll tell you the thing that
that that really stood out to me and I
think you're you're you're saying this
and and in your words but the thing I
try to convey to writing students is I'm
much less concerned about the noun and
I'm much more concerned about the verb
like I don't care if you're a writer I
care if you're writing right yeah and
and because there are plenty of writers
who stop writing and then all of a
sudden you don't hear from them anymore
and and what's that what's that worth if
you're not writing maybe you you once
wrote but also I can we talk about maybe
enjoying the process a little bit I know
there's like this old a Pithom
I am I fall outside the the norm here
there's a sold a Pithom though if riders
don't like riding they like having
written and and and for me I'm the
opposite of that I don't like anything
that I've ever written but I enjoy the
process of writing and I can go back and
look at things and say wow that was good
but I'm usually just neuro Singh over
like a comma splice or something but for
me half the time I want to put my head
through a wall writing sucks and it's
late how can I go through this the other
time it's elation and and there's
something about that the peaks and
valleys of writing there there's a huge
payoff for me so can you talk about that
in the broader context of forming a
habit like sometimes it's there is
drudgery and we have to Drudge through
the drudgery and other times there is
pure joy from or not even joy just just
satisfaction from the product that
you're producing well so some of this
can come down to just the habit you
select right like there are many
different forms that the same kind of
habit like let's take an exercise habit
right a lot of times it could be
strength training but not everybody has
to work out like a bodybuilder like you
could do hiking or kayaking or yoga or
pilates or you know a million other
things so choose the form of the habit
that is most enjoyable to you like
that's a good first step and there's no
reason to make yourself suffer that
reminds me of you know Matthew Vela our
good friend a director of our
documentary minimalism and when he first
like started on his own he stopped doing
client work and was after our
documentary came out and he started his
own website and he was picking other
people's habits and Soleil he's I guess
I'll start blogging because that's what
other people do but he's not a writer
he's a he's not bad at writing but he
didn't want to do it later was he he saw
what other people did and so he didn't
even want to think he would find any
real value from and he just saw this
other template but he realized like well
after doing it for a few months he's
like wait a minute I'm a filmmaker and
this is why am i blogging right and
that's a good example though right like
you can distribute a message in many
different ways it could be video could
be podcast it could be written it could
be something else but like choose the
form of content that is most satisfying
to you and and you can experiment with
that too I know it was
and we first started in fact it was
eight years ago we started the
minimalists and like eight years ago
today wasn't it um well the they were
recording this am I out here on the date
anniversary today's the day we're
recording this it's three days away from
the yeah but we started it was like it
was just a blog and that was one vehicle
right
I was picking that one vehicle now I
think we would have been really
overwhelmed how we said all right here's
the habits we want to build we need to a
blog we need to write three books
together and we started a YouTube
channel we need to go on nine tours in
eight years we need you know we got to
start a YouTube channel and then we got
to be on all the social media of
interest and and vine and whatever else
is out there and oh and we got to do a
podcast right I mean of course going to
do a video podcast we need a podcast
studio in addition to that we need and
you just keeps going and going and I
think that is often like the big hurdle
when when someone like Keanu says I'm
not a writer she says I have not fully
established
I haven't III haven't fully actualized
any of these things but we never
actualized it's a horizon and once you
get to that horizon there's always a new
horizon yeah what I like about wouldn't
when you write about how pushing through
that boredom like that is really where
the the habit takes takes hold that is
probably my biggest downfall is I will
start I mean with guitar it's like I
learned enough chords where if you put
some chords in front of me I can keep up
but like I got boring after a while so
now I've you know i still play guitar
every once in a blue moon but I'm not
super passionate about it but it's
because I haven't been able to or taking
the time to push through that boredom
maybe maybe speak can you speak a little
bit more to that about him so I have
this just kind of general idea that you
need to fall in love with boredom but
there's a fine line there so it's kind
of like two sides of this coin so the
first piece is I so I'm into
weightlifting I played baseball as you
mentioned for a while and then once I
got done I was looking for an outlet and
so I started doing some competitive
weightlifting stuff and one day this
coach came to our gym and he had worked
with some really elite athletes like
Olympians and things like that and I
asked him hey you know like what is the
difference
between these people who are like really
high-level and you know the rest of us
like me and he was like well you know
like some of the things are what you
would expect like genetics or you know
whatever their nutrition training
program that kind of thing but honestly
at the end of the day the thing that
makes the biggest difference is who can
settle into the boredom of doing the
same kind of lifts every day day after
day mm-hmm and a lot of people can't
handle that they get they use boredom as
a reason to jump to something new you
know it's like we're always looking for
the best diet plan or the perfect
business idea or the new way to like get
results faster it's not feeling it so
I'm just gonna go on move on to
something else and I don't know why we
do the store sales like I I had a guy
that I trained with who I mean he's
incredibly strong and he was making
progress on this squat program he was
doing and then I didn't see him for a
few months and I came back to him was
like hey how's it going and he was like
I yeah training hasn't been that good in
the last month and I was like well what
you know are you still doing that
program that was working so well he was
like no I was like well why not and he
basically just got bored of it and it's
like dude if like you know don't
complain about not getting a cake if
you're not gonna follow the recipe yeah
like it's just falling in love with
boredom that is Kevin Rose brought that
up when we were on his podcast and like
that concept it's almost like if I could
train myself when I feel bored to
realize like oh like this bored feeling
this is what I this is what I need to
feel right now in order to you know get
to this next step I mean I could almost
see myself getting a little excited be
bored well it gives you a way to reframe
it but here's the challenge this is the
other side of the coin so there's this
concept I talk about later in atomic
habits called the Goldilocks rule and
basic idea is that like imagine you're
playing tennis right and so if you play
against a professional like Roger
Federer or Serena Williams or something
it's gonna get boring pretty quick right
it beat every point right if you play
against like a four-year-old it might be
cute but if you're trying to play like a
real game that's gonna get boring cuz
you don't win every point I don't know
man you're the guy who goes to the
hospital and like beats kids and mad
about
you can't score one bucket on you really
guys so you're absolutely right but if
you play someone who's like your level
right you win a few points they want a
few points you have a chance to win the
match but only if you really try I was
just thinking the same thing man Ryan
and I are aggressively mediocre at ping
pong like we like to live in but it
usually like will be a twenty point yeah
I mean almost like Ryan wins fifty-one
percent of the time but it's mostly
because he performs really well under
stress and I don't so yeah but yeah
you're right and it's the reason I enjoy
that if I've tried to play with Ella
it's like god this is terrible
well if you can be in that zone what I
would call the Goldilocks zone not too
hard not too easy just right you know
like you're the human brain loves
challenges like that of just manageable
difficulty you know it's like you could
make this happen but you got to put some
effort in that's where you get into like
a state of flow where you're you know
fully engaged and your attention is all
in the moment because you're you're not
bored by it you're right on that razor's
edge of your ability and so if you can
manage that then you can avoid a little
bit of this downfall of boredom right
how do I fall in love with bored or
whatever and so this is why sometimes
it's important to like graduate your
habits to increase the difficulty just a
touch and I really like this concept of
like can I get one percent better each
day because it's small enough that it
seems easy to do and it is in many cases
but you're never staying static right
you're always looking to grow a little
bit and stay on that edge of your
ability and it's hard to know exactly
what that is in a lot of areas in life
but that general philosophy of can I
nudge this just a little bit more so ya
can keep you engaged I'd love that
approach because like when people ask me
about habits they'll say oh I want to
eat healthy I want to exercise and I
want to start writing help me out yeah
and it's like usually usually what I'll
say is well you know pick one habit and
start there but with this one percent
increase
you could even so you take many habits
break it down to one habit okay I'm
gonna choose this one habit but then you
can eat take that one habit and then you
could break it down to many pieces and
essentially like the habit of eating
healthy right there's like all kinds of
stuff associated with that you have
grocery shopping habits
you've got like food prep and chopping
habits you have cleanup habits and you
could you could just pick one of those
and try to get a little better at that
right but it's all still organized
around the same mission of eating
healthy yeah absolutely the the example
I remember using in your in your book
was working out it's like maybe your
goal is you want to get to the gym you
know five times a week and when you get
there for 45 minutes instead of focusing
on like alright today's Monday I'm gonna
get up I'm gonna I'm gonna start going
to the gym today I'm gonna go for 45
minutes and I'm gonna do that
consecutively for the next four days
that isn't as easy as saying okay today
I'm gonna get up and I'm gonna put my
workout clothes on and then tomorrow I'm
gonna get up I'm gonna put my workout
clothes on and then I'm gonna I'm gonna
step outside and then maybe you get to
that point we're going to the gym for
five minutes
but once you start just incorporating
these one percent increment changes it
starts to give you a bit of momentum
it's like the gal you talked about in
New York City where she gets up every
morning and she's like she goes out to
the curb she weight weighs the cab down
and she's like bringing me to you know
whatever gym that she goes and works out
to like that it that's the habit right
there it's not getting to the gym she
works out for two hours everyday but the
real habit is hailing the cab because
she knows if she does that the rest of
its and I do the same thing I mean I've
been working out for years but it's
changing to my workout clothes that's
the thing that if that happens
everything else will just happen it's a
side effect
yeah I'm thinking of two things one is
an extreme example of an agoraphobe but
people a person who's afraid to leave
their house right quite often when they
work with psychotherapists or
psychoanalysts they it is developing the
habit of today I'm going to touch the
doorknob and then this week I'm going to
practice doing that I'm going to turn
the door now eventually until I can get
one step outside right and and then
before you know a month or two months
three months down there all of a sudden
they're outside and had you forced them
to do that on day one they would have
panicked and shutdown and never want to
do it again I think the same thing is
true with habits if the CrossFit thing
there are some people who can go do
CrossFit and all the sudden that it
becomes their new habit usually they
have a certain level of baseline fitness
to start with right
however a lot of people are overwhelmed
by that
so they they'll do it and they'll feel
so sore the next day that it's like I am
that friend to have done this but
they've just like dude I did that with
the peloton like you didn't I was like
oh I'm gonna bread the peloton every
single day oh yeah I did try that for in
it lasted eight days and I was about
dead and yeah so I think it's a good
point the other thing I'm thinking about
is the 30-day minimalism game are you
familiar with this it's something that
that we've had tens of thousands of
readers and listeners do it's a way to
develop a habit so the way that in by
the way I think guess today's the first
day of the month so it's a great time to
start basically the average American
household has 300,000 items in it and so
we're overwhelmed is like I want to get
rid of stuff but I have no idea where to
even start right and so we found a way
to make decluttering a little bit more
fun with some friendly competition
because I don't know about you but for
me the just the thought of decluttering
is really boring I have to go clean out
my closet or my garage or my basement
that sounds awful I'd rather do anything
else today but we found a way to make it
a little bit more enjoyable with some
friendly competition here's how it works
at the beginning of the month so today
you partner up with someone a friend a
family member a co-worker someone that
you know and you both say we're gonna
get rid of some stuff this month the
first day of the month it starts off
really easy you get rid of one item on
the first day of the month and so you
talk about improving 1% each day that's
essentially what we're doing here except
we're just going our the number of days
corresponds to the number of items you
get rid of so day two it's two items any
one get rid of two Ives it doesn't
matter which item just pick an item on
day one day two two out and say three
three items starts off get you that
momentum you need by the middle of the
month it gets more difficult but you
already have that momentum so day 15
you're like oh wow I have to get rid of
15 items today and tomorrow I have to
get rid of 16 items and then on day 20
I've to get rid of 20 items and you bet
whatever you wanted to begin in a month
so whoever goes the longest throughout
the month wins if you both make at the
end of the month and you've gotten rid
of about 500 items and it's a really
good start we've had tens of thousands
of people share it on on social media so
if you listen to this at home and you
want to check it out it's just the
minimalists comm slash game and you can
check out the hashtag they're like
literally there's like tens of thousands
of pictures
we'll stop there the people are getting
rid of is amazed well and some people go
beyond a month 31 I'm getting rid of 31
I'm gonna day 365 well it's funny
thinking about the the men's game
through your lens you've got you've got
this atomic approach where like you are
on the daily basis kind of making these
small improvements you've got
accountability hmm but then you also you
got an accountability partner but then
you also have this accountability with
with you know what you bet what the
reward is or what the punishment is if
you if you lose the game and it reminds
me of the contract that you talked about
in your book just so this is like an
extreme version of like how to motivate
yourself but talk about the contract
that this dude did with training yeah so
this guy named Brian Harris entrepreneur
he he wanted to lose weight and get in
shape he had I think they had had one or
two kids at this point so he's just like
I don't know you know being a parent of
young kids is crazy and he hadn't worked
out as much as he wanted to and he just
like wanted to get healthier and so he
hired a personal trainer but he wasn't
making the progress he wanted and so he
came up with this what I call a habit
contract and so he wrote down he did it
for each quarter so it was like a
three-month span he wrote down you know
my habits for this quarter my goals are
gonna be the following I'm gonna you
know weigh myself each day I'm gonna go
to the gym four days a week and I'm
gonna you know like follow the following
nutrition plan or whatever and then if I
don't do those things the punishments
will be the following and he he's a huge
Auburn football fan so he hates Alabama
so if he didn't fall through he had he'd
have to wear like an Alabama hat every
day for the whole quarter or he is an
entrepreneur and doesn't want to dress
up and so he like often wears jeans or
comfortable clothes so if he didn't fall
through he would have to wear like a
actual suit or like nice clothes and
anyway so those are the punishments yeah
and then at the very bottom he said you
know if I do not follow these things
I'll have to fall due the following
punishments and consequences and he
signed it his wife signed it and his
personal trainer all signed it seems
like an overkill doesn't it it seems
extreme to me when I first heard it I
was like man it just seems like overly
formal right to have to like make a
contract for yourself and sign it
but I was asking him about it and he
said I swear to you the thing that makes
it happen is signing it like that makes
it real and he did it and it worked he
stuck right he stuck to all his habits
for the quarter so it made another one
for the next quarter and that worked and
yeah as far as I know he's still using
yes I mean I think it's like an extreme
example but it's not so extreme like it
makes me want to do habits contract with
you Josh
like I will let you win at every game of
ping pong I will have to wear a Michigan
hat so there's one more point I want to
come back to which you mentioned this
idea of like falling in love with the
process right and this is true for
pretty much any habit to stick that and
talk about this in the book the fourth
stage of a habit is the reward or the
satisfaction or on the other side of
consequence but basically whenever a
habit is followed by a pleasurable
feeling it is like a positive emotional
signal to your brain that says hey this
felt good you should do this again next
time and so what you find are that bad
habits form readily because they often
provide that immediate satisfaction
right away you know like if you eat take
a lot of bad habits like eating a cookie
or eating a doughnut pretty much every
behavior produces multiple outcomes
across time so like the immediate
outcome of eating a cookie is great it's
sugary its tasty its favorable the
ultimate outcome if you repeat that
habit for two months or a year or
whatever is unfavorable and with good
habits that's often the reverse like the
immediate outcome of sitting down to
write rather than watching Netflix is
kind of like unfavorable it you'd like
are forcing yourself to do something you
don't really feel like doing or giving
up on something it might be more
satisfying or the immediate outcome of
like going to the gym is effortful and
you sweat and you know like it's hard
work but the ultimate outcome if you
stick with that habit for two months or
a year is favorable and so a lot of the
balance of falling in love with the
process of figuring out how to stick
with good habits in the long run is how
do you take the long-term rewards that
delayed gratification and pull it into
the present moment yeah and I think that
people who are do that well who stick to
habits for the long run one of the
things that they do that doesn't seem
obvious at first glance is they find
alternative ways to be satisfied in the
moment so like I just gave that fitness
sample right like you go to the gym and
the immediate outcome is it's kind of
effortful and hard but it doesn't really
feel like that to me when I go to the
gym like I I think oh I get to see some
of my friends and I get to move my body
today and I focus on like how it makes
me feel in the moment rather than dress
right there like all these things that
happen right away and if you can shift
your attention to the immediate benefit
then it feels like oh I'm enjoying the
process and then I also get the
long-term benefits of maybe the scale is
lighter in 30 days or maybe I'm stronger
in six months or whatever yeah so it's
really not that much about delaying
gratification but about finding
alternative ways of immediate
satisfaction I love how you talk about
the in your book you talk about this
like sandwich inge a reward with the
habit and then a reward so like for
example it would be I'm going to have
I'm gonna wake up I'm gonna have a cup
of coffee and then I'm gonna write and
that that could be your trigger for
writing or for Josh it's just waking up
like that's a trigger for writing but
then after after you have written you
can say okay now that I've written now I
can watch a little bit of Netflix now I
can give myself an hour on Netflix or
maybe it's an hour of video games but
I've never really explored that approach
and I know that actually is kind of to
you like you took two things to kind of
sandwich it together and you weren't
there but but yeah just finding ways to
essentially like you said man like make
the short come the short term worth it
basically well so there yeah there are
kind of two things going on there so the
first is what I call habit sacking and I
first learned this from BJ Fogg as a
professor at Stanford but basic idea is
you take the habit you're trying to
build and you stack it on top of one you
already do so if you make a cup of
coffee every morning then you could say
after I make my morning cup of coffee I
will meditate for 60 seconds and that's
how you like layer that meditation have
it in but then you can also do what you
mentioned which is a special form of
habit stacking where you use temptation
bundling is what it's called but you
take something you want to do when you
pair it with something you need to do so
like I heard from one woman who she
always had these overdue working emails
and she's like I need to be better at
processing email but she wanted to get a
pedicure and so she created this rule
for herself where she said I'm allowed
to get a pedicure but only if I answer
over
working elsewhere that Jordan or if you
respond to your emails on time you're
allowed to go get a pedicure this is
like she could sit there on her phone
while she's getting a pedicure
Yeah right and respond and respond you
know there's like another story in the
book of this engineering student who he
knew that he needed to be working out
more but he was just binging Netflix all
the time and so he linked up he used his
engineering degree and linked his
computer to his stationary bike and so
whenever he wasn't pedaling
Netflix would pause and so it's like he
was allowed to watch Netflix but only if
he was cycling it made me think like
that dude should just mass manufacture
those bikes oh I think about the month
pretty good or the year with some some
of my best habits ever that really a lot
of the habits that I have now where that
they have become routine it was when I
removed a lot of those distractions
right and so I did a whole bunch of
experiments after I left the corporate
world so I was thirty thirty one at the
time I got rid of home Internet I got
rid of TV at home I got rid of my cell
phone for a couple months and you were
confronted with a special kind of
loneliness when you've removed those big
pacifiers the TV the internet and your
phone and you come home and you're like
well I have a computer but it doesn't do
anything except let me type into it and
what are those things on the shows all
those are books if I remember how to
read and and it allowed me to sit with
that boredom you mentioned getting good
and getting comfortable with bored and
boredom there's a book about boredom
it's David Foster Wallace's last book I
don't know if you ever read it's called
The Pale King no I haven't but so a
whole book is about boredom it's it's
fiction but it takes place in 1985 in
the IRS office in Peoria Illinois I mean
I can't think of a better a backdrop for
extreme boredom then 1980s IRS office
this is somewhere there's a poor IRS
employee listening to this but this was
what I even had like computer so it's
everything was just these forms and like
it was I mean the whole book is about
boredom but what you realize
is the the whole book is mimetic of the
actual routine of boredom leighton it's
beautiful
there's something really gorgeous about
the writing of the book so it's gorgeous
throughout but there's also a particular
payoff if you get all the way through it
it's a boring book but it's plus it's
supposed to be boring it's set up to be
gorgeous and boring at the same time and
you have to Drudge through that boredom
in order to get the payoff and the
payoff is worth it if you're willing to
sit with that boredom for that long and
so I think that is like the perfect
metaphor for any habit you're building
is sometimes it's going to require some
boredom in yes especially up front Keanu
you were not going to be good at I mean
anything anything you're going to do
you're not going to be good at at first
it could be basketball or sex or fishing
or skiing or reading or weightlifting or
writing they all take effort to get good
and also I think you have to reframe
what good is right now good for you is
gonna be different from good for someone
else good for you might be just getting
that one sentence out a day that is good
and then you can build on top of that
good and make it great eventually yeah
Keanu I'd love to send you the two
things one is I want to send you a copy
of atomic habits we got James here so
maybe I can get him to sign this and
we'll podcast out and you can send this
to her or if you want the the audiobook
I'm sure we could get you an audio book
copy of that as well oh yeah okay
beautiful yeah and so we'll we'll send
you either one of those or if you want
the eBook version we'll send you one of
those as well and then also since you're
talking about writing I have a writing
class it's called how to write better
and if you're listening to this you can
find in a Hal to write better org but
Keanu it's a four-week class I want to
give you that class and hopefully as
long as you're willing to commit to it
commit to the habit for 30 days of
writing I've got some some tips some
literature and also some of my own
personal best practices that I think
will help you through the the habit of
writing but also getting better at
writing and building on top of some of
those fundamentals like grammar and well
there's just a whole there's a bunch of
resources in those I think you'll find
value in Keanu so how to write better
org Shawn if you could reach out to her
and give her both of those atomic habits
and how to write better I'd appreciate a
and uh one other thing I forgot to
mention
Ryann one of the best things I ever did
for my writing and and you alluded to
this James was start a blog she said she
won't start journaling and I think
that's great
but if you want to be held accountable
publicly and a public who can be with
your seventeen Facebook friends as well
starting a blog somewhere it could be
literally to starting a blog on Facebook
Facebook has Facebook notes feature now
or starting a medium blog or tumblr or
whatever Ryan and I have a guide on our
website of how to start a blog exactly
what we did the whole process we were
really clueless I tried to like design
an HTML blog like at first I had no idea
what to do and coming up like a month
later he's like dude we can't do this
like HTML he's like I have no idea I've
got to go to college to learn how to do
HTML I couldn't even spell HTML I was
trying to like like figure out how to
build a blog and then we figured out all
the appropriate steps so if you want to
follow the same recipe that we followed
Keanu or anyone elses listen to this
good just go to the minimalists comm
slash blog you can see exactly what we
did also we have on there like 20
recommendations for your blog 15 reasons
to start a blog 3 reasons not to start a
blog one of them has to do with money
and so yeah you can find all that there
at the minimalists comm slash blog all
right and we'd love to hear what you all
have to say so if you have a comment or
a tip for any of our callers today
including any advice for Keanu or anyone
else leave us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm will
air our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips James is my favorite
part of the show
where people call in and they give us
their their comments and tips and we get
to steal them and reappropriation
Ryan what time is you know what time it
is it is time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do so James we're on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram at
the minimalists and during the lightning
round sort of Ryan and I each do our
best to answer every question with just
a short shareable less than 140
character response now we do pontificate
for a little bit yeah yeah
we monitor on we build up the the the
sediment and then we triangulate your
way to it yeah they respond and then
potash on will tweeze out the most
perfect line yeah in the show notes and
sometimes I'll just pick out a bunch of
words out of random order and create
something beautiful we call the minimal
Maxim's you can find all of our minimal
Maxim's in one place thanks to our good
friend Jessica land Williams over at
minimal Maxim's com it's all our pithy
answers from the minimalists what's our
first question Ryan our first question
is from herb herb writes in I have ideas
in my head of so many good healthy
habits that I have researched thoroughly
and want to implement in daily life that
will make me healthier and happier but I
never get around to starting do you have
any tips on how to snap out of it and
just get started
well my I alluded to this already but my
pithy answer to this see I had a head
start I already knew what the question
was James my pithy answer is subtract a
subtraction is greater than addition and
really the thing is like i talked about
my morning routine where i had all of
these these sort of things that were in
the way right and and and they prevented
me from doing my habit the habit i
wanted to call it because i in truth i
had all these other sort of ancillary
habits like i have to do the dishes
first thing and the more i have to do
this i and they weren't they weren't
leading me to the person I wanted to be
there were actually habits that were
getting in a way of the habit that I
wanted to to truly develop and so I
think with with herb one of the things
that he's talking about here is I have
so many habits that I want to start
right I have I have ideas in my head of
so many good healthy habits that I've
researched thoroughly actually I'm herb
I'm the one that wrote in
this is your ghost account like Kevin
Durant here yeah you're also the ones
giving me [ __ ] on Twitter all so what do
you say James he has ideas for all these
good habits he's thoroughly researched
how did he how does he get started with
implementing all of them immediately in
his life yeah well we talked about one
of them already two-minute rule
so take the habits down scale it so that
it fits into two minutes or less so
that's first idea second thing is don't
worry about doing them all at once right
like time is gonna pass anyway so you
might as well focus on mastering one of
them get it make it your new normal make
it the standard in your life and then
you can add the next one you know a
month or two or three from now and the
next years gonna pass regardless so if
you get to the end of the next year and
you've mastered three or four or five
that's great but you don't need to do
all five at once it's way better than
continuing to thoroughly research the
Hat correct right in let's say you've
got five things on your list and at the
end of the year you can look at one of
them and say oh man I really was able to
I mean you feel so much better that's
gotta feel great yeah right like you're
undeniably better off than you were
before absolutely so so two-minute rule
focus on one at a time and then the
final thing that I'll add which can be
very useful and that goes back to some
of the things we talked about before a
lot of people wake up each day and think
they need more motivation when what they
really need is clarity and what I mean
is that we start each day and we don't
necessarily have these basic details
figured out about our habits like when
and where are you going to write you
know okay you want to build the habit of
writing what time will you do it where
what you do is gonna be at home it's
gonna be somewhere else or like you want
to go to the gym great you know are you
gonna work out at a home gym are you
gonna join another gym and have to drive
there if you're gonna drive are you
gonna like go before work or after work
do you need to bring your own water
bottle or is there a water fountain at
the gym and like all of that those like
little logistical details they sound
like not much but when you are trying to
build something new that falling into a
pattern where it's like oh you know I
always go to the gym and I forget my
water bottle and they don't have a water
fountain there that's enough to get
someone to quit early on yeah and so be
very clear and specific you can
literally fill out a sentence that says
like I will exercise on this day at the
time in this place and there are over a
hundred research studies that show
despite that sounding basic that people
are much more likely to fall through on
their habits if they write down when and
where they're going to occur I think of
our friend Rob Bell who was so inundated
with like meetings and all these other
things that were going on and at his
place of work is the church that he was
running and in Grand Rapids that he
rented a little office space probably
similar to this this room that were
sitting in here because he needed a
place to go by himself for two hours a
day and right yeah and that's all it was
it was a desk and a chair it was a
writing office yeah that he went there
and no one else was welcome yeah and he
excluded everyone for those two hours so
he could go sit there and and write and
he picked a time he knew when he was
going to go there everyday and also the
the and maybe this extends to that the
habit thing he and it's a Hemingway
thing to you always you stopped in
mid-sentence sort of thing or for him it
was like my two hours are up even though
this is going really well I'm going to
stop right now so I have somewhere to
pick back up when I start writing
tomorrow and as opposed to like emptying
the gas tank and burning yourself I'm
gonna write for 14 hours today and then
tomorrow you're like oh crap I can't top
that I might as well stop well think
about how different that experiences -
cuz he finished every writing block
there and he people wanted to stay he
wanted to kit was going well he's like I
wish I could be here longer and so then
he thinks back to like going to that
place it's like yeah I want to get back
there every time I'm there I feel like
the time goes too fast yeah and that's
why I think sometimes it can be very
useful to scale your habits down so that
you stop before it gets difficult no I
don't think that's a exactly what you
should do in the long run but it's great
in the short term you know like
journaling stop journaling before it
gets hard before it feels like a hassle
exercise do something that feels easy in
the beginning make it like so easy that
you can't say no to it or you're like I
just want to keep doing this and then
you like start to associate some
positive feelings with that habit and
that makes you want to come back yeah oh
yeah I was just gonna say one of the
things that stood out to me not only
what you were talking about with Rob
Bell Josh with kind of stepping outside
of your normal environment because in
your book you talked about how you know
if you want to sit down in your living
room and start writing well where you
where you're living
used for it's used for watching TV maybe
it's used for listening to music maybe
that's where you play board games
whatever it is if that's the family room
it's like - then also add in writing
with that room that is that can be a
detriment so stepping outside of your
environment I think is a is a great
point but the only thing - man that
really stood out to me in your book was
the pointing and calling oh yeah so like
this is this is a concept that James
talks about actually I'm gonna do a bad
job paraphrasing and just talk about
what they do in Tokyo with sure - yeah
so so I if you go to Tokyo if you Japan
has one of the best train systems in the
world and I actually was in Tokyo
earlier this year and I saw or I guess I
should say last year how was I there
earlier this year on January 1st so
anyway they they had this system that
they referred to as pointing and calling
and the basic idea is when the train
pulls into the station you'll see the
conductor will like point at the signal
and say signal is green or they'll point
at the speedometer and they'll say speed
is 60 kilometers an hour or out on the
platform there will be other employees
that point up and down and say like you
know platform is clear and this system
the safety system that the Japanese
designed it basically engages multiple
senses right like you're saying it
you're pointing it out you are seeing it
as well and so it when you do something
everyday like a conductor pulling into a
station or an employee like helping
another train leave from the platform
and we do this we all do this when you
do something over and over again you
start to get a little numb to it it just
becomes you know boring it becomes
habitual and you start to when you can
do it good enough on autopilot it's easy
to overlook your mistakes it's easy to
not try to find a quest to do it better
and so pointing and calling raises that
level of awareness to a more conscious
level and you identify mistakes and as
luck or bad luck I guess in this case
would have it I actually saw the system
save a woman's life while I was in Tokyo
so we were on the platform and this
family came up and they had I think four
sons the youngest one was probably like
6 or 7 years old and they got on the
platform and he just walked onto the
train because he thought over up on the
train platform this were going but
actually they were waiting for the next
one and so he accidentally gets on the
train the doors closed and his mom sees
him on there and so she runs over and
sticks her arm in and she thinks it's
going to be
like you know the elevator doors were
like it closes and then they opened back
up but actually it trapped her arm in
the door and so her she's in there
holding her son he's like crying at this
point and the Train which is one of the
Shinkansen 'he's the bullet trains that
go like 200 miles an hour is about to
take off and there was an employee on
the platform who did the pointing and
calling that looked up and down and
noticed like platform is not clear and
was able within like three seconds to
radio the conductor and stop it and the
train stayed there they open the doors
they got the kid Alden in a minute later
at left and it's just a good example of
a system like that can make you more
aware of the things that you do
habitually and help you notice mistakes
airs things that are not quite right and
when you pay attention like that it
becomes easier to spot those mistakes
and correct them yeah well I was the
reason why I bring that up is because
with starting habits I mean sometimes
first you got to realize the habits that
you already have right and you know what
what you talked about in your book is
like list out all the habits you already
have I wake up in the morning I brush my
teeth I make my coffee I unplug the
toaster you know these are the habits
that we all already do put next to each
habit like is this a positive is this a
negative or maybe it's ambivalent you
know brushing your teeth I guess would
be positive waking up is kind of
ambivalent like you're gonna wake up no
matter what I can't say I'd be sad if I
didn't wake up I just wouldn't know but
but you know and then going through that
list but then also as you're going
through your habits pointing and calling
like I'm getting ready to eat this
doughnut and this doughnut is a negative
impact on my life and go I need the
doughnut but if you are calling it out
and it's it's different to I feel than
just thinking it mmm saying it out loud
or writing it down makes it much more it
just makes it more real it makes it sink
in a little bit more and if you're
calling out every single morning
eventually you're gonna get tired of
hearing yourself treating your body so
poorly right there's gonna be something
that clicks to to hopefully initiate you
know some kind of different habit or
some kind of change I know for me the
the the habit I have now I've had a lot
of health problems the last two and a
half three years some pretty significant
health problems
I'm dealing with a SIBO bacterial
overgrowth and my small intestine right
now and it is agony is the word that I
realized that I've been going through
the last three months and I can tell you
one thing that keeps me sane at this
point is the certain habits that I have
even when I don't feel like I can't do
this like I'll show up for it even if
like writing yesterday as an example
like I sat down to write and like I was
in pain from from everything that's
going on I just couldn't do it but I I
at least I showed up right and for me
because I've been showing up for so long
I know that like that is the most
important thing and I for me it keeps me
saying still still exercising maybe I
can't do what I was doing because I
don't have the energy to do it but
showing up to do something is better
than just throwing my hands up and
saying well I guess I'm I'm dead to the
world I like to say like you know even
if you say you have a crazy day you
traveling you're on the plane for five
hours or whatever and then you get to
your hotel and all you can do is five
push-ups before you like collapse on the
bed yeah but at least you're the type of
person who didn't miss workouts yeah and
like that it doesn't sound like much on
any given day but counts for a lot in
the long run
because you have this story in your head
now where it's like I don't feel good
the situation was not optimal it wasn't
my best day but I still was able to show
up yeah yesterday I had a horrible day
working out like I would like you know
just second set in I'm like I'm not
getting as many reps as I usually get in
it was it was later in the day I took 20
pounds I could barely benchpress 150
pounds like your bench pressing almost
300 pounds the weights are a lot the
toilets were all the wrong direction
everything
what's your pithy answer Ryan yeah so so
my pity answer is this start small with
a new habit even if you start with a
small failure so going back to working
out like I did for all intents and
purposes I failed yesterday like it was
not an awesome workout but even even at
its worst
it's still better than doing nothing
even fail even you know trying and then
not getting a hundred percent result
that I expected and failing somewhat I
wouldn't much rather be in that position
than then doing nothing at all all right
the next question is from Jamie how do
you break the habit of never saying no
arising the the the byline for the that
pop star movie never stop never stopping
I stole that for an essay that we have
about screen with Saturdays we do this
thing called screen with Saturdays every
Saturday which we'll talk about here in
a little bit but and because that's kind
of what it feels like with social medias
like I can never stop like we don't even
live in a 24-hour news cycle anymore
it's like in every hour every 15 minute
news cycle on it's like hey man you
didn't hear about what the president did
or the blah blah blah and it's like no I
didn't hear about it yeah man it was 17
minutes ago and you're like yeah I'm not
caught up I'm sorry and so so I think a
Jamie's question is especially relevant
today because we're saying yes to almost
everything and so my short answer here
is and I love to hear what what your
take is on this James my short answer to
Jamie's question Jamie's asking how do
you break the habit of never saying no
whenever you say yes to something
unimportant you're saying no to
something important and I call this yes
itís like we're always saying yes
because we feel bad what someone asked
us to do something even though some we
don't know it's someone on Twitter or or
Instagram or you know whatever it's a
distant Facebook friend who you remember
a little bit from high school but you're
not really sure when last time you saw
them lest they ask you for something
it's our because we are wired to be
around you know 40 or so people
someone says ask you something you're
wired to say yes because you want to
build that that tribe but now we we're
we are faced with unlimited numbers of
input and these unlimited numbers of
discrete bits of input we feel like we
had to say yes to each of them not
realizing as I say yes to this bad habit
I say yes to this bad habit yes to this
one each one individually isn't that bad
but when you add them all up I've said
yes to a bunch of unimportant
and it's forcing me to say no to the
things that are most important to me
yeah yeah I mean yes is a form of time
debt no is a form of like time option
right like if you say no to something
you still have the freedom to do
whatever you want with that block of
time if you say yes to that podcast Sean
that's that's pithy if you say yes to it
then you can only use that block of time
for that one thing right and so I
sometimes I like to say like no is a
choice or no is a decision yes is a
responsibility right because like as
soon as you've said yes to something
you're responsible for showing up and
doing that thing for that block of time
but the question that I would ask myself
if I was dealing with that and honestly
I am dealing with this a lot right now
you know like atomic habits has done
very well
tadaaaaaa bestseller list done you know
the launch is incredible whatever and we
had to say yes to a lot of things didn't
make all that happen right but now we're
on the other side of it and we've have
all these things coming in and now I
need to like switch and start learning
to say no to stuff and like be careful
about prioritizing time and things and
that's a good problem to have but I
think the the lesson ayat that I'm
coming to realize is it depends on what
season you're in in your life so the
question to ask is like what season a
million right now so like for me in a
broad sense this period of my life is a
very career heavy season I don't have
kids yet I'm very focused on my personal
health and my career and so on but at
some point I'll have kids and that will
signal a shift to a new season and so
when I'm in a new season my habits seem
to shift as well and so I think that
there's a place for yes but it's not in
perpetuity right it's not it's not it's
needs to be like a careful a carefully
well-defined season you know it's we
talked about this we did a podcast with
Jordan Harbinger couple weeks ago on
business and one of the things in
business that I realized when we first
started eight years ago my pithy answer
to that question was say yes until you
have to say no and then say no until you
have to say yes and and because so for
us like when you like so the book launch
is a good example of that right so so
you said yes yes yes because you've
wanted this thing to reach the people it
needed to reach and in order to do that
you had to pick the appropriate channels
that were willing to act as a megaphone
to get this message out there right
and so not only were you tapping into
your own existing audience at James
clear calm but but you were going out to
these other media outlets etc and and
and using their platform to explain why
it's important for people to take a look
at their habits and so you're saying yes
to all of these things at the same time
at some point it's gonna become
overwhelming you can't do that in
perpetuity
so when Ryan and I first started the
minimalist we just said yes to
everything yeah you CBS wants us to come
out we'll flatten in New York and do
that or yes the the Today Show wants to
come out we'll do that in fact this year
the day she was asked to come out I said
no but you can come here right and so
like it was it was about making a change
it was sometimes it's a no but we can we
can do this sometimes it's just a hard
no like no and so whenever I say no to
someone and I think this would be
helpful for Jamie I tell them what I'm
saying yes - and so I've got a request
to be on someone's podcast someone a
friend of ours actually I'm going to say
no to it and the reason I'm gonna say no
to it so I could spend time with my
family like legitimately not the pull of
the politicians I'm quiting to spend
time with my family but but like like
legitimately like if I say yes to this
I'm gonna have to say no to spending
this hour or two hours with backs yeah
it's a good practice to like clarify
while you're doing that at yeah adding
clarity is is important because it's not
just saying hey it's not it's not you
it's just like I have only so many hours
in the day and here's how I'm going to
spin those hours I would rather do this
thank you for understanding is always
the thing that I think it's important to
like even in those moments where the
seasons where you are saying yes to a
lot of things like my book launch for
example I was still saying no to like
almost everything else right like I was
saying no to learning a musical
instrument even though I think that
would be cool but like this isn't the
right season for that or I was saying no
to cooking classes even though it'd be
great to be a better cook or in like a
million other things sure it was just
yes but in a very narrowly defined area
right yeah I think that that we don't
realize that because it's not
we're altima saying no to virtually
everything anyway right right the
instrument thing is really good because
if if someone were to come to you and
say Ryan I need you to learn how to play
flute
you're pretty easily gonna say no to
that because of the time commitment and
your lack of interest etc but when
someone comes to you with a small ass
I'll just take an hour of your time and
it's like just now are my time but it's
also not were your time you're never
gonna get back yeah and it absolutely
does give a pithy answer for a couple
pithy answers one thing that you talked
about your book man is how you know you
said maybe it's not maybe it's not
impossible but you've never really have
known someone to stick with a good habit
in a toxic environment so like I gained
someone's stick to positive habits in
the negative environment yeah so so I
mean if I was - like just paraphrase and
I'd say you can't stick to good habits
yeah in the toxic environment so first
and foremost like Jamie you've got to
make sure that you are surrounding
yourself with people who who want to see
you empower yourself who when you say no
they support you if you're around a
bunch of people who expect all of these
things out of you and then you say no
and then they start to bring you down or
whatever it may be it's going to be very
very hard for you to get into the habit
of saying no if you are surrounded by
toxic people essentially you're saying
you're saying yes to all of these things
it's like you're you're in a hamster
wheel man and then you're not actually
going anywhere you're constantly
fighting off the sort of bad habits of
other people yeah and then the other
thing I would say - and this is with any
habit it's and we talked about this
earlier find ways to make bad habits
immediately unpleasurable and learn how
to appreciate the long-term rewards so
what I mean by that is is that when you
say yes Jamie and you know you shouldn't
have said yes like you are gonna have
that immediate pain of like oh I just
over committed but how else can you
really associate saying yes with a none
pleasurable feeling and then you know
conversely like when you say no how can
you really bring in that that long-term
reward and look forward to that of the
good habit yes
RIA yeah so yeah I think that that's an
important distinction to make because
habits as you mentioned early on they're
not automatically good or bad I have it
as simply a habit and also the meaning
that we give to the thing like
good habit for one person might be a bad
habit for someone else right and I think
that to keep that in mind
PS Ryan we have three more questions
here today also I want to talk to James
you don't have kids so I find people
don't have kids are the best people to
talk about let me tell you what I do
stupid kids I do want to talk about
building habits with kids because Ella
is at an age now she's in kindergarten
and she's picking up not just her own
habits but the habits from the kids
around her the peers she is she is like
ultra impressionable right now yeah and
I find that she's even picking up habits
from like YouTube you know cuz kids love
watching YouTube now so so I don't know
you know how everyone starts their damn
YouTube videos with hey guys so now Ella
or an other kid saying hey guys like
just starting out sentences oh hey guys
dude I heard about this kid was getting
put to bed and they told that earlier
like 2 or 3 years old and they told her
mom please like and subscribe like that
is how that is how they learn to say
goodbye kids habits but then I also want
to answer Bernie's question about
foundational habits Bernie says are
there any foundational habits that one
should implement first that will help
with all subsequent habits and then
Editha asks I tend to give up if I quote
fail or quote cheat on a habit how do
you handle the frustration of when the
habitual streak is broken and the
finally fira asks what is the most
simple yet life-changing habit you have
and if you all would like to hear our
answers to those questions and you can
listen to this week's post script
episode over at the minimalist private
podcast that's right every week we
record an additional podcast episode
this week we'll have James clear on
there and it's available exclusively to
our patreon subscribers so if you want
to support our show and keep this
podcast 100% advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support please like and subscribe
[Laughter]
in addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our ask the minimalist
anything episodes we do one of those
every month also unreleased recordings
of our live events last year we did I
think
tene live events that we released on our
patreon feed just for our patreon
subscribers and also the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes we're
approaching a hundred private podcast
episodes over there on patreon so once
you become a subscriber you'll also
receive a personal link to our private
podcast feed so that it plays in your
normal podcast play or whatever you're
using listen to this podcast right now
our private podcast will also play there
it's just a separate feed just for our
patreon subscribers find all the details
and all the good stuff including an
additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists comm slash
support and by the way I heard Sam
Harris you all know Sam Harris maybe
from our documentary or from many of his
books that he's written he's a great
podcast called the waking up podcast and
he was telling people about cuz he
doesn't do ads on his podcast either and
he was talking about like I know some of
you subscribed to this because I provide
you with like these bonus episodes and
like ask Sam anything or he goes it's
great if you wanna support me for that
but that's not the reason you should
support my show support it because it's
important and I think it's helping other
people and I don't want to have to do
advertisements and so I would just like
to echo that sentiment like if you wanna
if you want to keep getting this this
for free because you can't afford to
support our podcast and you'll keep
getting it for free we're doing our best
to do this without advertisers but we
pay Sean we paid Jordan we pay for a
studio space Ryan and I literally make
zero dollars off this podcast all of you
I would like to make some money from
patreon eventually Sunday but we're
easing it right now to pay the people we
need to pay and support it because you
think it's important if you think the
show is important and you're willing to
support us just a couple dollars makes a
huge difference the minimalists com
slash support and plus you do get a
bunch of good stuff as well but that
should be the reason there should be a
nice little bonus for you so here is a
snippet from this week's PostScript
episode
[Music]
the lesson here for parents is that you
still have a strong influence but one of
the best levers that you can pull for
influencing the habits of your kids is
the type of environment that you place
them in the type of peers you put them
around because you have control over
what city you live in what schools they
go to what extracurriculars you expose
them to I think back to like I played
baseball but I also swam every swimming
team I was on all the kids on those
teams are smart it's like if you look at
the swimming team at my college they
have the highest GPAs like swimming in
cross country every year
crushed it fueling your kids to have
good study habits that's one example of
like it doesn't guarantee it but place
them in an environment where that's what
their friends are going to be doing
because when habits allow you to fit in
when the type of thing your friends are
doing anyway they naturally become more
attractive and it's much more attractive
for them to be like oh all my friends
act this way too than it is for you to
be like you should be doing this
[Music]
okay now it's time for our added-value
portion of the shows where we talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently Ryan I'm gonna start
which we just ended a year and it was
one of the best years for music that I
can remember in a long time which is
actually hard to believe because music
had become so ephemeral now there's
there's hardly you know we don't it's
not the same experience I used to go to
the CD store in Middletown Ohio and
that's a Ryan and I used to go what was
a CD connection yeah we go to see the
connection about that so James is from
Butler County so he gets the Middletown
reference and and I remember like there
it wasn't ephemeral it was like it was a
whole experience at getting dropped off
listening to the CDs and lay it and now
it's just like oh there's 17 new albums
that came out on Friday that I want to
listen to I can't listen to all of them
especially since I'm listening to all
these damn podcasts like we're we're
inundated it's it's the beauty of of the
the removal of all the gatekeepers but
at the same time we're flooded with with
content which is not a word that Ryan
and I are fans of because there's so a
lot of content out there there's not a
whole lot of meaningful creations so
surprisingly there were a lot of amazing
albums in 2018 it's been a good year and
so at the end of every year I've done
this every year since we started the
minimalists I do my top 10 or top 12
albums of the year and I've been working
on it this past week and so hopefully by
the time this episode is out it's done
isomer 1 so for Phoebe Bridgers oh I've
not listened to that yet you saw her in
concert though she had been up for the
national it was a great great opener
yeah she her album is like kind of
beautiful songs about sadness and but
it's like it's like la angst in a way
cuz she's from LA and but lay eggs never
heard that before but that resonates so
well with me it's a great album she also
did this it's a great album title LA Ink
that could be a Phoebe Bridgers album
title she did this trio with two other
female singer songwriters
the tree is called boy genius and it is
really good - it's like an EP it'll
definitely on my list or at least be on
the honorable mentions because I don't
even know an album is anymore either
like Kanye West did the whole seven song
thing for a whole month this year they
had a bunch of albums that were seven
songs that used to be an EP so anyway if
you are a fan of all kinds of strange
eclectic music there's everything from a
pseudo country album in rust and Kelly's
album which is definitely my top five
albums of the year it's it's it's like
country without the twang it would be
like LA country music even though he's
from Nashville I think it's it's just
beautiful songwriting it bridges the gap
between singer songwriter and country -
I mean great like down south rap albums
like MBA young boy was like my favorite
rap album of the year and so there is
everything in-between Phoebe Bridgers
Matt Nathanson and that whole list you
can find at the minimalists calm slash
sound it's the SA there is called the
sound of euphony nice dude I I'm gonna
recommend I know this seems kind of lame
but it's really really awesome actually
so Mariah and I we we we always have the
different shows in common and will binge
on stuff or like you know if we're gonna
sit down and watch something on Netflix
we'll usually watch like the office or
Seinfeld or something that we have both
seen a million times and like we can sit
there and laugh and it's dude what's
funny when Mariah and I watched like the
office for example we are constantly
repeating lines back and forth to each
other like such a good show it's it's
it's it's hilarious but she had never
seen Game of Thrones so I was like you
know what because I had I had actually
got the you know the HBO app to watch
that special the comedy special that you
recommended oh dude I forget I forget
his name Michael yeah the drew michael
comedy special which in its own right
like i will recommend that that we've
already recommended on the show but
that's a really i think we have
recommended it's great but it's it's a
great comedy special and it's also it's
a comedy special where the dude had no
audience which was it wasn't quite it's
just incredible but but since since i
had got that to watch that special
I was like man Game of Thrones is on I'm
like my let's start watching Game of
Thrones and dude watching her she had
never seen it watching what you had yes
and watching her watch it is like it's
it's own thrilling experience you know
that reminds me of so we had Peter
Rollins on the podcast do an episode
about love and on his podcast which is
called the fundamentalists he and his
roommate comedian friend they were
talking about how one of the best
reasons to have kids is so you can
really fin Santa Claus now I don't
actually propagate the belief of like
there is some man who's going to break
into our house once a year and leave
behind material trinkets that I didn't
want him to leave behind anyway but it's
fun to get in this period but Ellis
seems to believe in Santa Claus no
matter how much I tell her he doesn't
exist yeah she did
and and so and she'll ask her mom like
certain questions why doesn't why does
he get stuck in the chimney and and at
this point back she's just like I don't
know why why do you think he doesn't get
stuck in a tree I think he uses the
front door and but you get to like re
experience you're almost your childhood
in a way by by by having a child who is
experiencing those emotions for the
first time and you're doing the same
thing with Game of Thrones yes it's it's
pretty awesome so I would recommend like
just if you've got someone that you can
you know binge watch some TV with like
go to one of those shows that they've
never seen that you love and like just
watch their reaction to it Game of
Thrones specifically though because of
the way that that show plays out I'm
just gonna give a little bit of a
spoiler alert here it's like well pretty
much dude it's like watching watching
her fall in love with these characters
the same way I did numb and I want to be
like don't fall you're gonna be
devastated that's why from the beginning
I try to tell ll like it's a fun story
it's made up just like they heard the
cartoon she watches of a Daniel Tiger
and Peppa Pig they're made up as well
they're not real you know and she
understands that but she for some reason
think Santa Claus is real and I don't I
don't want to spoil it for her but at
the same time I kind of do want to spoil
it for her that's that's hilarious James
is anything but adding value to your
life recently
so many things alright so I have a
couple so sticking with the habits theme
there are two Chrome extensions that
I've used this entire year that I have
loved so one is called Facebook newsfeed
Eradicator which you just add it to your
Chrome browser and you can log into
Facebook you can use it and check your
friends profile if you want but there is
no newsfeed it's completely blocked so
you don't see any posts and then the
second one is called distraction for
YouTube and so you another Chrome
extension you add it to the browser and
you can click on a link and watch a
YouTube video but all of the suggested
videos in the sidebar blocked so it's
just like a blank screen with the the
video so there is there is no like
alright I'm just gonna watch this one
more video
lastly Zimmerman has that Joker is like
you know you go to watch a youtube video
and then 20 minutes later you're
watching a interview with Justin
Bieber's mom and you're like how did I
get here it's like for me it's eight
hours later I was drooling on myself
host mates is bringing their second
order podcast John Key put a link to all
the things we mentioned in the show
notes today I would appreciate it let's
move on to right here right now so we
talked about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalist so one thing
that we've been doing for the last three
months is something called screen low
Saturday's and it's because we've done
different experiments experiments in the
past where we've gotten off social media
for a month or we you know I told you
earlier I got rid of my cell phone for a
few months whatever and we said well
what's a what's a smaller increment in
which we can learn we can temporarily
deprive ourselves for a day to see what
we learn from the whole process so this
there's three ways to do screen the
Saturday and for those of you who want
to take a look at it it's just the
minimalists comm slash screen las' but
the first way is just like a social
media fast so you know you're not really
screen unless you're just saying I'm
gonna stay off social media all day on
Saturday because we're constantly
bombarded right we never stopped never
stopping with social media and quite
often it's the first thing we reach for
in the morning it's like I must gotta
check Twitter Instagram real quick and
like a bunch of pictures that I didn't
know existed 30 seconds ago and so
that's the first way to participate in
screen 'la Saturday it's just get off
social media for one day the second way
to participate is get off your computer
- so no computer and no social media we
call that one already call them a
digital downtime and then the third way
is truly screen 'less you go all the way
in no screens all day on Saturday no TV
no phone no screened-in porch he's
definitely for the Midwest screened-in
porches yeah
so the first screen ly Saturday Mariah
and I did I was like man what are you
get what are we gonna go do I'm like
well we don't have let's go walk it to
see a movie and I'm like wait a minute
so Ryan he got puppets and write reenact
she had to be caught up on the first one
not yeah so you know it's I learned a
lot that first Saturday cause like I
went to go to the car and so backs I
just go out and we explore for the day
and like we go get lost together like
that's sort of the intention like
because we don't have a GPS and we just
go out and we don't I don't have my
phone with me and so well but it's a
great way to learn a city too because we
only lived in LA for a year and so you
get so reliant on the device it shows
you everywhere where to go right and so
like if you need to go somewhere you're
like I just go where the stupid thing
tells me to go I'll drive into the lake
of it tells me to do that that's why you
don't these Apple maps by the way it has
tried to drive you into a body of water
more than once oh my goodness huh and
and so although I hear it's much better
these days and anyway like we just gone
we get lost together but we also like we
went to a CD store for the first time
like they still exist there's one in
Hollywood where it's called amoeba it's
this giant it's like the last bastion
it's the last stronghold of physical
media and connections combined solid
yeah and we bought like two or three CDs
and we listened to them in the car but I
realized I was just renting the CDs
because I'm gonna use them they'll and
one CDs I got was a dollar and I'm like
well I'll just return this next weekend
and like get 50 cents back forward or
whatever and then if I want to buy
something else I'm essentially just
renting CDs for a day because I'm not
gonna hold on to them but this
this moment of temporary deprivation the
the whole point is like let's pause for
a day at the end of the day on Saturday
think about what was different write
down like how did you feel
did it feel less chaotic what did you go
without and some some Saturdays you
might I'm just gonna go without social
media
I know Becks did that last Saturday and
then last Saturday we the four of us
besides James were in this room so
podcast Shawn and Jordan and Ryan and I
on Saturday we did two things one is I
Beck's wasn't in town neither was Ella
so we spent about three hours searching
for a payphone
turns out payphones don't exist anymore
and we found one finally and then it was
not there it was like just a shell of
you know there was no phone and it was
just the pay phone booth yeah I realized
that Superman would have nowhere to
change these days he would be really
secure in neo would totally be screwed
oh yeah he would not be able to get out
of the matrix and and and so like we
started going around and just like
asking people with different coffee
shops where I was hanging out the window
where's a payphone and we spent like
three hours searching for a payphone and
then we went over to where the Franklin
Canyon yeah Franklin Canyon Park and is
that a super8 see if I can put this so
Jordan has this old super 8 camera that
takes film it's a relic man yeah it can
only have an original super 8 if you do
18 frames per second you can film for
nine minutes with this thing so we
filmed a video about screen 'less
Saturdays and it was and we use it Shawn
has this old like $20 cassette tape
recorder so we went fully analog
on-screen with Saturn we had that cuz
like we Jordan was filming with that and
PI watch us on YouTube you can see the
camera I'm holding up by the way yeah
yeah and then yeah there will be a
behind the scenes clip that Jordan puts
out about how we filmed that but the
craziest part was when we were filming
it I think was when Shawn had with his
recorder had to like you know hold and
just get perfectly out of the frame
sounds like substantial right yeah it's
good wait it's actual metal right it's
like yeah I feel like you could just
load a clip into this and hurt someone
I'm gonna do that Jordan calm down it's
a lot of fun yeah it was so we spent the
day doing that and then I [ __ ] you not
and you'll see this in whatever video we
end up putting out we'll put a link to
it in the show notes but at the very end
we we were driving out of Franklin
Canyon generated drive these guys home
and we drive past an actual pay phone
Beverly Hills in Beverly Hills
alright we're a payphone would be right
well it's funny cuz I knew for a fact
there was a payphone on Highland and
Franklin Avenue yeah in Hollywood but
Josh refused to get dysentery but that's
where you expect payphones to be is like
well we found several payphones even
found one that was still intact but
didn't work didn't work here then we
found the one in Beverly Hills and I was
able to call I was able to call backs
and then I talked to Ella on the phone
and Ella was so confused cuz she had
never talked to me on the phone before I
realized like she couldn't understand
and she said why can't I see you right
now I said because I'm on a payphone
she's like what's that and the in and so
no I'm not we're not out here saying
deprive yourself of technology what
we're saying is sometimes we could step
back from technology to figure out how
to use it more deliberately because
sometimes these habits that just come
into our life like I'm gonna get up and
check Twitter I'm going to get up and do
this on my phone I'm gonna reach reach
reach for my phone 60 times a day and
all of a sudden it is a habit that is
getting in the way of what we truly want
so check out the the video we did about
screen las' saturday you can find that
in the show notes this episode before we
move on to the rest of the right here
right now stuff I just want to say
thanks to James clear for joining us
today and if you all are listening to
this then I would encourage you to
follow him he's at James clear on
Twitter at James underscore clear on
Instagram and James clear on Facebook as
well James clear calm his book is called
atomic habit so you can check it out
wherever you get books these days and oh
and you've got a habits Academy course
over at James clear calm as well so if
people need some help additional help
with with getting their habits in shape
I think they can check out the habit
habits Academy over at James clear calm
James thank you so much for being with
other day yeah
I really appreciate it was great and I
by the way I need to ask you for a
dollar because this is our last chance
Ryan
so we're from a city called Dayton Ohio
and James grew up in Hamilton Ohio which
is right down the street from Dayton
Ohio and he lives in Columbus now so
right down the street from Dayton Ohio
as well Ryan and I are on the west side
of Dayton which we did not grow up in
the west side of Dayton but the west
side of Dayton is one of the largest
food deserts in the country 40% of the
population of Dayton proper lives on the
west side of Dayton and there is not a
single grocery store on the entire west
side of Dayton so I think about 40% of
one of the largest cities in the United
States does not have access to healthy
food right they have access to
convenience or food they can get you
know Cheetos and DeVito's yeah they get
a phat fed some fast food yeah you can
get some fast food they can get liquor
at the local corner store but they don't
have access to vegetables try that
liquor diet it is doesn't work speaking
of bad habits yeah yeah and we didn't
even dive into all of our bad habits
from our 20s right that's a totally
different episode that was the
addictions episode yeah so what we're
trying to do is we did we did this thing
over Christmas where people could buy a
brick to help us build this grocery
store we've we've raised close to a
hundred thousand dollars but we're not
there yet it's the last hundred thousand
dollars who need to build this three
million dollar grocery store on the west
side of Dayton it's called Jim city
market we partner up with the folks at
Jim City Market we're trying to raise
the final hundred thousand dollars to
build this thing and so what we're
looking for our audience to do is buy a
brick for a friend or a family member on
behalf of or on behalf of yourself even
so if you're interested in helping us
contribute in a meaningful way Ryan and
I are donating $25,000 of our own money
buying twenty five thousand bricks yeah
you should see the other podcast room we
have here we think you you didn't
understand the metaphor
although Ella she's been like we got
walks together she's trying to pick up
bricks and hand them to me now like this
will help your grocery store
yeah and and so if you want to help us
out it's the last chance so we can
really use your help we didn't make it
to $100,000 this is an example of what
you talked about earlier around with
failure like we we failed we didn't hit
our hundred thousand mark by end of the
year but it's certainly a whole lot
better us getting to like seventy
thousand dollars than us getting to zero
dollars right and so if you listen to
this and you want to help out donate a
dollar or donate however much money you
have it'd be really helpful just go to
the minimalists comm slash dayton and
that will get you over to the donation
page for jim city market you can get
more information over there as well also
on youtube right now besides our
podcasts which you can comment on if you
want to comment on this episode you can
do so over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists on our youtube channel you
can find quicky episodes of the
minimalist podcast you can find living
room conversations or ryan and i sit
down answer one question at a time in
our living rooms also house tours of
ryan's and my places coming soon
also there's a new poll that we have up
each week on youtube you could to vote
for which videos you would like to see
next on our youtube channel and we're
doing something called simple sundays on
our website and also in your email box
so if you if you want our new writings
or any new show notes that come out for
the podcast just go to the minimalists
comm and into your email address at the
top we'll never send you junk or spam or
advertisements because all of that stuff
is gross ryan what else you got for us
as usual i just want to encourage people
to read more and get informed oh and
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners this is Emma
from Adelaide in Australia now I have a
bit of encouragement for anyone who is
struggling to get rid of books I have
worked in the book industry for over 10
years now and needless to say I had
thousands it was out of control I
recently started calling them I didn't
realize until then the amount of stress
and overwhelm and anxiety they were
causing just having them living in my
house so I've started to get rid of
getting rid of them all I'm down to two
bookshelves now and I want to get down
to that hall of fame I just realized I
wasn't gonna read them and if I couldn't
be bothered getting them from a library
there was literally no point making
hi I wanted to call and say thank you
for giving me in my family perspective
on what really matters in life and as a
payback I'd like to share some
information I recently came across that
you may or may not know about Ronnie
where is an Australian nurse who spent a
few years living with people on their
deathbed and she ultimately collected
top five regrets of their life I
encourage you to look into it and share
that information it's really inspired me
in recent weeks and I hope it does the
same for you hello it's Katherine from
Littleton I would just listening to this
show on experiences and I'm a
50-something divorcee who also had to
part with a lot of things when she got
divorced and I went too late but Lady no
and I can't remember her name that it's
okay it's okay to let go and it actually
feels really good once you get through
it and you will survive and you don't
have to have all that stuff and yes your
kids will let you know what they want so
just let it go be free live your life
start a new journey all right Joe that's
it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalist give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine you can also email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm and if you leave here with just one
message today we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time minimus